which one is the pig in which one is
truly riding the other I would say that
my interior design aesthetic is playful
you know it might cause you to ask some
questions like wow where'd you get such
a cool big table and Wow are you okay
guys it is 2016 everyone's excited for
fresh starts and with fresh starts comes
cleaning out all of the stuff that makes
you awful I started rearranging some of
my stuff in my office space and then I
went on Pinterest and I just lost myself
I was knee-deep in walls made of plans
and office desks made of Target receipts
it was WOW so this morning I woke up and
I went to Ikea and I bought some things
to kind of upgrade my office space and I
thought that I would film it with you
guys a mom by killing maximum amount of
birds with minimal amount of stones so
I'm going to show you a couple quick
things that I've done to renovate my
space maybe it inspires you maybe a fish
maybe you're just a person that doesn't
like anything and wants to live in
misery because it's comfortable familiar
and you don't think you deserve anything
better good luck with that so let's get
right into it here's how my space looks
currently
so the first thing I'm going to do is
replace my desk
I've had this desk since I moved into
this house because I accidentally
ordered the wrong desk on IKEA and I
thought that that's all I deserved was a
desk that mismatched and then I saw
making Mattoon for Marvel contact paper
on her coffee table and I did that on
the top of my desk but I did it real
silly because I didn't measure it and I
got the wrong size contact paper and I
thought that's what I deserve so I've
been living with this for over a year
time to change it we're not making each
other better people we should stop this
out so I'm going to clear off my desk
and bring in the new one to put together
with you guys because that's therapeutic
and fun putting together IKEA furniture
yeah
Wow can you see this chili applied
contact paper here is the line another
cross-section and it's covered in scum
but you know for those of you that can
do this well this isn't a bad trick it's
like when you put bronzer on your face
and you contour it to make it look like
you have very cutting cheekbones and
you're very you know worthy of love this
is like turning something that's gross
into something that's more worthy of
love so I are one of those desks that
can go up and down insert your sexual
jokes here who's got a lamb chop toy the
other day we're all upgrading this is
the desk I got it looks great really
beautiful we're gonna put it together I
just already feel depressed
yes I'm you're curious are you helping
no you're hurting
you're hurting me emotionally thank you
robot feet look at me I'm taking on my
true form this is more pieces than I
thought it's like when you date someone
you think that they're real simple
person and then you realize whoa they're
complicated as [ __ ] I'm going to take my
sweatshirt off provocative thumbnail I'm
not crazy I'm just wearing a t-shirt
with my dog's face coming out of the
pocket because we're healthy and happy
you don't need to see this that is
something that resembles a desk oh my
god I am a god that's pretty cool humans
can do incredible things when they have
such urge to procrastinate on the more
important things that they should be
doing desk completes oh good everything
is weird next thing I want to do is add
some greenery to my space some plants
but I can't keep plants alive on account
of my selfishness so I got some
artificial plants this is like dyeing
the hair of your workspace it's not real
but a good
one can give you the illusion that you
are much more capable I got all these
fake plants look how capable I look
already I look like I'm like good at
math and my taxes I got these there's
little bars but I am going to put it
underneath of my windows and I'm gonna
hang these things on them with plants
we'll see if this works out this is
called big gal because by adding this
sort of mature decor to my room I seem
like a real big girl okay that seems
about centered ish who has time for
measuring I probably do but not right
now
effects is that oh it went in crooked oh
my god you're doing it look we did it I
can hang dishtowels on it and hold on to
it and then earthquake like just when I
want to feel supported or I can add
these guys hell then I can add my plant
whoa oh my God look at that hey new
friends you have to love me okay good
talk okay the last major piece of an
office is a chair and the last thing I'm
going to show you is a DIY to update any
plain office chair that I saw on
Pinterest who the mi-2 be fair though
I'm doing this DIY next to an old
mattress that I have yet to get rid of
so still the same old grace I've had
this chair from Ikea for awhile and I
don't love it how this hurts my legs not
worth it a lot of places are selling
these free chairs that look like you're
sitting on a pointer you're doing squats
but I saw a hack on Pinterest for
recreating that look what you need is
office chair a couple full sheets skin
things I got this from Ikea or like an
Ikea price some scissors and a hot glue
gun so the first thing we're gonna do
is take one of our sheepskin things
we're going to wrap it over top and then
glue these sides together here so I'm
going to take my hot glue gun which is
too far away now and I'm gonna hot glue
these sides together this might be
working I have this extra stuff at the
bottom here that I think I'm just gonna
tuck up and glue underneath am i making
interesting content okay now we're gonna
work on the cushion part turn this over
I'm going to put this face side down
this already has this rounded edge here
that I can go with hey hey and I'm just
going to kind of fold it then how to cut
it and wrap it okay BAM tada now instead
of chair completely back together oh
look at this updated chair holy [ __ ] I'm
actually extremely impressed with myself
we have been through a time today and
now it's time for my updated workspace
after thank you guys so much for
watching do not forget to subscribe to
this channel also leave me a comment
down below what was your favorite part
of this maybe this was helpful maybe
this inspire you maybe this wasted your
damn time
either way cool that you're alive I
don't know I use the cutting board as my
mouse because I can't stop being
Pinterest now King beautiful floodgates
are open and you know what
I decoupage the [ __ ] out of those
floodgates they look great